[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT: PageSpeed Insights--
it's a great tool just
for performance,
because it's, like,
desktop speed, mobile
speed, and UX, as well.
ADDY: The UX side is
really interesting,
because you take the tool-- you
take a site like Hacker News,
for example.
Try to look at it on
mobile, try to put it
through PageSpeed Insights.
And what you'll notice is
that the UX scores there
will actually show you images
showing where they can improve.
So they've got really small
touch targets, for example.
MATT: Yeah.
ADDY: Meaning that,
if you go on a phone
and you try navigating
around that, you're hosed.
So they could probably
fix that, maybe?
MATT: Yeah.
ADDY: Something we
also recently added
to PageSpeed Insights was the
ability to just go and download
optimized images and optimized
CSS and other resources.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MATT: [INAUDIBLE], yeah.
ADDY: It was like a
subtle little link
underneath all of the scores
you can go and check out.
I would say you're going to
get a different pack of stuff
depending on whether
you're in the mobile view
or the desktop view.
MATT: Eh.
ADDY: But it's
worth checking out,
even if you don't use them,
just to see what kind of savings
you could get.
MATT: It's interesting to see
it, but the other side of it
as well is you kind of
want it in a build process.
ADDY: Right.
Right.
MATT: Because the minute
you change anything,
you don't want to have to, then,
run through PageSpeed Insights
to then get the downloaded
stuff, and, yeah.
And obviously I ended
up doing a video
on PageSpeed Insights for
last year's I/O, so, you know,
there's that.
ADDY: It's almost
an upsell-- that.
MATT: No.
ADDY: No.